-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with Tariq Trotter
from The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And we are about to play
a new game,
called Flip Shots.
Here we go.
-♪ Flip Shots,
Shots, Shots, Shots ♪
♪ Flip Shots ♪
-But first, we're going
to need some players.
He stars in the
critically acclaimed
HBO series "Succession,"
which debuts its fourth,
and final, season this Sunday.
Please welcome Kieran Culkin!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow.
- ♪ Flip Shots ♪
-Kinda cool.
-Game on?
-Yeah, game on.
Game on?
-Plus, he is
a legendary rapper
and member of the Wu-Tang Clan.
Give it up for Method Man!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Flip Shots, Shots, Shots ♪
♪ Flip Shots ♪
-[Indistinct], baby.
-Alright.
Here's how it works.
When I say go, we're all going
to start flipping our cups,
okay?
Now, if your cup lands upright,
you move your shot glass
one square forward
towards the person
across from you.
We keep going until the shot
glass crosses the red line.
If it lands on your side,
you have to do a shot.
You can choose from one
of the following...
[ Ohhs ]
[ Cheering ]
-Yogurt water?
-Yogurt water is the water
that floats on top
before you --
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
-It's good.
It's good for you.
-Probiotics.
-It's a probiotic.
Thank you, Tariq.
[ Laughter ]
We're going to play
three rounds.
You guys ready for this?
Meth, you ready?
-No.
-Yeah, I'm ready.
-Alright, let's --
[ Laughter ]
let's take our positions.
You're over there.
Method Man, you're over here.
-Yep, I gotcha.
-Good luck.
-Alright. Good luck.
Oh!
Are you going to flip a cup?
-Man, this a cultural thing.
Black people don't do this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Alright, alright, here we go.
Alright, let's go.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And here we go.
-3, 2, 1, go!
[ The Roots playing hip hop ]
[ Cheering ]
-Oh -- Oh, that's how you...?
That's how it work?
-Suck it.
-Dang.
-Aah!
-Oh! Oh!
-I'm not drinking yogurt water.
-Yes, you are.
[ Laughter ]
-[Bleep]
-Faster!
[Bleep]
-Come on, now. It's got to be --
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
Come on, [indistinct], come on.
[ Laughter ]
[ Voices overlapping ]
[Bleep]
-Come on.
-Nice save.
-Oh, [bleep]
[Indistinct]
Goddamn it.
[ Cheering ]
-Nah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Aah!
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Ohhs ]
-Get him! Get him!
[Bleep]
-Sorry!
[ Cheering ]
[ Laughter ]
-Hard as shit.
-Go, man. Go.
-Come on, you son of a...!
-Man!
[ Cheering ]
Oh, no!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Rimshot ]
Oh!
Ah!
-Bang bang bang!
-I'm exhausted!
I'm exhausted!
-Oh!
-Yo, you got three easy ones
to choose from.
-Yogurt water.
-[ Laughs ] I'mma save that
for you, Kieran.
Give me pickle juice.
-Oh! Come on.
-I'll take the pickle juice.
-Easy one.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Over the teeth,
through the gums ♪
♪ Watch out, stomach,
here it comes ♪
-♪ Shot, shot, shot ♪
-Ohh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Oooooh!
Pickle juice!
-I got to get my lick back.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here we go.
-Going again?
-We're going again.
Round 2 here.
It's...
[ Rimshot ]
3, 2, 1, go.
[ Cheering ]
Schnark.
Oh, come on.
Of course, now I'm choking.
Oh, smuh.
I suck.
-Cup.
[ Grumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
Aaah!
Aaaaah!
[ Laughs ]
-Aah!
No-o-o!
Aah!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Rimshot ]
-[ Laughing ]
-iAy ay ay ay ay!
-Oh, come on.
-You're going to take all three.
-Oh, man.
-I'm sorry, bud.
-Go for the yogurt water!
-I'm saving that for you,
K-Dawg.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, you got to go.
-Tabasco.
[ Ohhs ]
-It's a lot.
It's a heavy shot.
You want to do it in to shots --
If you want to do it
in two shots, you can.
-Do it in one.
Do it in one.
-♪ Shots, shots, shots ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Shots, shots ♪
-Ohhh, my God!
[ Rimshot ]
Oh, my God!
-Oh!
-Whoo! Whoo!
-Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Wow.
-Dude, he's going
to be hot right now,
so I want to like
hurry this game up.
-Done! Game over!
-I'm so sorry.
Aren't you happy you said yes
to this game?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-The yogurt water's going
to cool it down. Don't worry.
-Dude, who knew you were so good
at Flip Cup, man?
Alright, here we go.
Last round.
This is for the yogurt water!
-1, 2, 3, go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-It's not happening --
happening again.
This is not happening.
-Yeah, it is.
It's happening.
-Aah!
-[Bleep]
-Come on, baby, no.
Agh!
-Do it, Do it!
-Agh!
-There we go.
-What is my problem?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Aah! Gosh!
♪♪
Aah, yeah, yeah.
You can move it back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, please, no!
Please, no.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Aah!
-Please, no.
-Get him. Get him.
-I'm going to get him.
I'm going to get him.
-Get him. Get him.
Please get him.
[ Cheering ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh! Oh!
[ Rimshot ]
-iAy ay ay!
[ The Roots play mariachi tune ]
-You're welcome.
You're welcome.
No problem.
-Watch.
[ The Roots playing
upbeat tune ]
[ Cheering,
clapping rhythmically ]
Seriously.
-♪ That yogurt water ♪
-Let's go.
-Damn it!
No, I know, I know!
-♪ Shots, shots, shots ♪
-[ Chanting ]
Shot, shot, shot, shot,
shot,
shot, shot, shot,
shot, shot, shot, shot,
shot,
shot, shot, shot,
shot, shot, shot, shot!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-[ Coughs ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That was nice. That was nice.
-Good game.
-My thanks to Kieran Culkin,
Method Man --
My, you really stepped it up.
Did you plan that?
-Ah, man.
-We're talking with Kieran
after the break.
Stick around.
Good job, Tariq.
-Good game. Good game.
Good game. Good game.
-iAy!